it was about two years after Hurricane
Katrina that I first saw the Louisiana
flood maps these flood maps are used to
show land loss in the past and land loss
that is to come on this particular day
at a community meeting these maps were
used to explain how a 30-foot tidal
surge that accompanied Hurricane Katrina
could flood communities like mine in
South Louisiana and communities across
the Mississippi and Alabama coasts it
turns out that the land we were losing
was our buffer from the sea I
volunteered to interact with the
graphics on the wall and in an instant
my life changed for the second time in
two years the graphic showed massive
land loss in South Louisiana and an
encroaching sea but more specifically
the graphic showed the disappearance of
my community and many other communities
before the end of the century I wasn't
alone at the front of the room I was
standing there with other members of
South Louisiana's communities black
native poor we thought we were just
bound by temporary disaster recovery but
we found that we were now bound by the
impossible task of ensuring that our
communities would not be erased by sea
level rise due to climate change
friends neighbors family my community I
just assumed it would always be their
land trees marsh bayous I just assumed
that it would be there as it had been
for thousands of years I was wrong
to understand what was happening to my
community I had to talk to other
communities around the globe
I started in South Louisiana with the
United Houma nation I talked to youth
advocates and Shishmaref
Alaska I talked to Fisher women in
coastal Vietnam justice fighters in Fiji
new generations of leaders in the
ancient cultures of the Torres Straits
communities that had been here for
thousands of years were suffering the
same fate and we were all contemplating
how we would survive the next fifty in
the next by the end of the next century
it's predicted that more than 180
million people will be displaced due to
climate change and in south Louisiana
those who can afford to do so are
already moving they're moving because
South Louisiana is losing land at one of
the fastest rates on the planet
disappearance is what my Bayou community
has in common with other coastal
communities erasure is what communities
around the globe are fighting as we get
real about the impacts of climate change
I've spent the last 14 years advocating
on behalf of communities that have been
directly impacted by the climate crisis
these communities are fighting a
discrimination within climate disaster
recovery and they're also trying to
balance mass displacement of people with
an influx of others who see opportunity
and starting anew it's since 2005 people
have been called refugees when they
leave when they're displaced by climate
disaster even when they don't cross
international borders these terms these
misused terms that are meant to identify
the other the with the victim the person
who's not supposed to be here these
terms are barriers to economic recovery
to social integration into the healing
required from the climate crisis and
climate trauma words matter it also
matters how we treat people who are
crossing borders we should care about
how people who are crossing borders
today to seek refuge and safety are
being treated if for no other reason
than it might be you or someone you love
who needs to exercise their hee
right to migrate in the nearby future we
must start preparing for global
migration today it's a reality now our
cities and our communities are not
prepared in fact our economic system and
our social systems are only prepared to
make profit off of people who migrate
this will cause rounds of climate
gentrification and it will also penalize
the movement of people usually through
exploited labor and usually through
criminalization climate gentrification
that happens in anticipation of
sea-level rise is what we're seeing in
places like Miami where communities that
were kept from the waterfront are now
being priced out of the high ground
where they were placed originally as
people move away from the coast
these folks are being moved forced to
relocate away from the social and
economic systems that they need to
survive
climate gentrification also happens in
the aftermath of climate disaster when
massive amounts of people leave a
location for an indefinite amount of
time we see others come in we also see
climate gentrification happen when
damaged homes are now green built but
now have a higher value generally
outside of the reach of black and brown
and poor people who want to return home
the price difference in rents or the
ownership of a house is the difference
between being able to practice you're
right your human right to return home as
a community or be forced to resettle
somewhere else
less climate resilient less expensive
and alone the climate crisis is a much
larger conversation than reducing co2
emissions and it is a much different
conversation than just extreme weather
we're facing a shift in every aspect of
our global reality and climate migration
is just one small part but it's going to
have ripple effects in both coastal
cities and in cities and the interior
so what do we do I have a few ideas
first we must reframe our understanding
of the problem climate change is not the
problem
climate change is the most horrible
symptom of an economic system that has
been built for a few to extract every
precious value out of this planet and
its people from our natural resources to
the fruits of our human labor this
system has created this crisis we must
have the courage to admit we've taken
too much we cannot close our eyes to the
fact that the entire world is paying a
price for the privilege and and comfort
of just a few people on the planet it's
time for us to make society wide changes
to a system that incentivizes
consumption to the point of global
imbalance our social political and
economic systems of extraction must be
transformed into systems that regenerate
the earth and advance human Liberty
globally it is arrogance to think that
technology will save us it is ego to
think that we can continue this unjust
an extractive approach to living on this
planet and survive
to survive this next phase of our human
existence we will need to restructure
our social and economic systems to
develop our collective resilience the
social restructuring must be toward
restoration and repair of the Earth's
and the communities that have been
extracted from criminalized and targeted
for generations these are the front
lines this is where we start we must
establish a new social attitude to see
migration as a benefit a necessity for
our global survival not as a threat to
our individual privilege collective
resilience means developing cities that
can receive people and provide housing
food water health care and the freedom
from over-policing
for everyone no matter who they are no
matter where they're from what would it
mean if we started to plan for climate
migration now sprawling cities are
declining cities could see this as an
opportunity to rebuild a social
infrastructure rooted in justice and
fairness we could actually put money
into public hospitals and help them
prepare for what is to come through
climate migration including the trauma
that comes with loss and relocation we
could invest more of our time in justice
but it cannot be for temporary gain it
cannot be to help budget shortfalls it
has to be for long-term change and it
has to be to advance justice it's
already possible y'all after Hurricane
Katrina universities and high schools
around the u.s. took in students to help
them finish their semester or their year
without missing a beat those students
are now productive assets in our
community and this is what our
communities our businesses and our
institutions need to get ready for now
the time is now so as we reframe the
problem in a more truthful way and we
will structure our social systems in a
more just way all that will be left is
for us to rien digitized ourselves and
to conjure a power of the
ancient kind this necessarily means that
we must learn to follow not tokenized
not exotic I not dismiss the leadership
and the traditional knowledge of a
particular local place it means that we
must commit to standards of ecological
equity and climate justice and human
rights as the basis a base standard a
starting point for where our new society
is to go all of this requires us to
recognize a Power greater than ourselves
and a life longer than the ones we will
live it requires us to believe in the
things that we are privileged enough not
to have to see we must honor the rights
of nature we must advance human rights
for all we must transform from a
disposable individual society into one
that sees our collective long-term
humanity or else we will not make it we
must see that even the best of us are
entangled in an unjust system and we
must acknowledge that the only way
you're going to survive is for us to
figure out how to reach a shared
liberation together the good news is we
come from powerful people we come from
those who have in one way or another
survived so far to be us here today this
is reason enough to fight and take it
from your south Louisiana friend those
hardest fights are the ones to celebrate
let's choose to make this next phase of
our planetary existence beautiful and
while we're at it let's make it just and
fair for everyone we can do this y'all
we can do this because we must we must
or else we lose our planet and we lose
ourselves the work starts here the work
starts together this is my offering
thank you for receiving it mercy
[Applause]